so you say you know my uncle yeah he's
crazy though
you owe his uncle money don't you mind
no that's what i heard i'm
worried about you mike what the [ __ ]
up man give me some money
[ __ ] up out here
[Music]
hey everybody it's jeremy piven we're
back here at hot boxing and of course
i'm with the great
mike tysonia mike is amped up and ready
to go and we are so honored to have
saquon barkley daequan in the hit out
thank you guys thanks for having me
before we get into into your world
do you have a favorite running back of
all time yeah
um barry sanders harry sanders yeah
barry sanders it's interesting because
i'm from chicago
so mine's walter payton sweetness
yeah god you can't go wrong with that
one either no and i have to say
you know you're one of the great running
backs and every time i run into a great
running back i asked him the same
question
no disrespect to your boy but usually
they say walter payton i would say
walter is probably the greatest
all-around running back you asked me my
personal favorite i'll say barry
just because barry is special with the
balls
it looks good it's just art emotion
poetry in motion
um walter payton is a monster
yeah you know i i was like
indestructible monks
correct mike you guys you all feel like
you're come from the same cloth i
was lucky enough to sit down with
sweetness and i asked him
what was who hit the hardest and he told
me that
he doesn't know who hit the hardest but
he said one time he stiff-armed the dude
reached underneath his pads and before
he threw him off
he said he felt the dude's heart beating
in his hands
and threw him to the ground and that
scared the [ __ ] out of me i got to get
this
with you that's from the level stuff
right there's another level right i've
never personally
i've personally never experienced that
it's different than a guy and feeling
his heartbeat but
you're 23 right yeah um do you ever just
sit in a dark room and you
visualize yourself being the greatest
running back since the creation
of god uh i was i would say yes
especially
um i just hurt my knee this year turn my
knee to my knee up but
i'm a big visualizer i'm a big person
that believes in
having conversations with yourself
that's something my dad kind of taught
me um
and no i know what it's called it's
called affirmation affirmation the guy
named miguel
kuwait he's the father of affirmations
talking to yourself talking things into
existence that's where it starts at i
mean if you want to like
for me that's the whole goal like my
whole goal is to uh
be the greatest run-back to ever play
and i feel like if that's not what
you're doing it for you're doing for a
wrong reason
and it starts there you have to build
that confidence in yourself and it's
those moments when you're talking to
yourself and you're alone or um
even if you're saying you're working out
and you're pushing yourself during that
that last rep
it's that conversation with yourself uh
even though i agree with you even right
here in the room while you're talking
it's going to you exactly yes sir
so have have you ever been injured like
that before no uh no
um definitely humbling man i mean uh
when something that you love and you're
passionate about so much
it's taken away from you and you're just
sitting there watching on the tv
and you can't even go that's pride yeah
that's pride yeah it's just breathtaking
sometimes because
you're not unable to do what you
normally do every day yeah
so it's been it's been tough um saquon
means gift from god i think i've
just seen that right now yeah i told you
some warrior stuff
so you you you you hinted on a little
bit of
perspective which is almost a gift
you know that gratitude of the journey
you've been on because you're so young
and yeah i'm that he's young and
conscious
you know how long it took me to
understand that i was taught by
you know masters and stuff the average
guy would never even run into that
you know really average guy would never
run into the consciousness
i mean he was heavyweight champ at 20.
yeah the youngest ever right
right but i had to be it before i turned
20.
i had to be the heavyweight champion
subliminally
subconsciously emotionally
if or every iota in my body had to be
that
before i even was that yeah you got to
visualize it because if you don't
visualize it it would never come
come to life yeah you know what i mean
yeah and i i like
obviously i'm not at the level where i'm
at yet uh where i want to reach
by any means but that's something that i
i study
the greats i look at your videos i look
at
cody rest in peace kobe bryant uh the
michael jordans and
you know the mindset the mental part of
it and i feel like um especially doing
this
uh this injury um hopefully god willing
that's gonna
be another thing that helps and take me
and and catapults me into the direction
i want to go
it's also the good look at their
weaknesses too
yeah because you'll find that in some
people
they're special their weaknesses and
their flaws are their biggest assets
because they have they have a they have
a tug of war with them sometimes the
flaws win
the name of the game and psychologically
to overcome your flaws
and not to get discouraged when every
now and then they win
yeah that's a great that's a great point
because that's i feel like a lot of
people get caught up in that
we always see like a success never get
discouraged
confidence breeds success and success
breeds confidence
yeah confidence is supplied properly
with super theater genius there's
nothing like confidence
it's like a it's almost like magic you
can't even see confidence
yeah can you see it you can't even see
it in the person it comes across
as being braggadocious
but you can feel it oh you could feel
someone's conscience you could feel it
you just can't convey it it's so
difficult to convey it even in those
moments you can feel it like
it's sometimes like going back to
visualizing things like
maybe that night before maybe the week
of going into a game
you're sitting there and you're
visualizing making that play and
within the play i don't know if it's the
same thing whether you're in a fight
but within that play save as a special
play it looks so great to everyone but
in that moment it literally like
it's like that and you're really like
it's like a blink of an eye you don't
realize what you're doing
and especially when your confidence
that's something that i had to go from
uh my confidence level in high school
especially obviously i just growing up
and maturing but that's something that
had to to be honest getting stealed in
from my dad
you know i always had the talent but um
my confidence level was
so low and i almost gave up on on the
sport football and
um and my dad told me you quit one thing
in life you're going to be a critical
lesson
and probably got that from you to be
honest
but and that's something that that right
there from that moment on
um it kind of just clicked for me and
it's still clicking i'm still not where
i need to be
i'm still not where i want to be but um
you know i don't think it hurts to have
conversations it's your birthday
february 9th what's that pisces aquarius
queries
you know i was always told that since
you said about that um
quitting stuff it's also told like this
be careful of the way you play your
games
okay because by the way you play your
game be the way you live your life
and it's true what do you mean by that
the way you play football
is the way you're going to live life so
you be careful how you play football
because
those same mistakes will be waiting for
you in life
to the lord thanks folks on the little
things the details
yeah that applies in life applies in
being a dad the way you treat people
that's what you're saying passion
passion
what would you say the difference is
because it's interesting as an outsider
looking in
to an arena like football you see these
guys who are achieving so much in
college
who even win the heisman trophy and
they're unable to transition into the
nfl
what's what's because you've been able
to do it and
ultimately people don't realize your
background because you had to be the
best player
on every field you stepped on to even
get to the nfl
yeah now you're with all those dudes
that are on the same level
and you've been able to exceed people's
expectations what's
what's the difference between someone
like you and someone that maybe had a
great college career
but wasn't able to transition well
there's so many factors that go into
that
talent the talent level is always going
to be there like you said you know even
if you're talented college
the talent level is not really too much
different in the nfl
uh because think about if you run a 4-3
in college like it doesn't matter
you're going to run a 4-3 nfl you're
going to four five four three four four
whatever
but it's just understanding the game and
it's like you got to be passionate about
it
like for me like team success
individuals team success has not been
uh where we would like it to be at all
and you can find yourself
um when you're losing a game not saying
being comfortable with it but
understanding like damn like we lost but
you gotta move to next week within
college
you lose one or two games the national
championship the playoffs everything
that you want
is not it's not there for you so i would
say the biggest thing is those guys that
that do not um come from college and
succeed in the nfl like i said a lot of
factors could be injuries could be stuff
like that but
it's how passionate you're about the
game if you're you could be as talented
you want
in college but if you're not passionate
about the game and you don't have that
work ethic there's going to be someone
that's going to outwork you
in the nfl so it's the variables your
work ethic everything you put off the
field
but it's also your mindset yeah your
mindset's everything and
that and that's something that like i'm
like i keep saying i'm nowhere near
where i
need to be but that's something i'm
trying to continue to go to like i said
i i'm
confident enough to say that i want to
be the greatest running back to ever
play but i know if i want to do that i
have to
have the right work i think have the
right mindset respect the players and
running backs before me
understand and watch their watch them
and see what they did to put them in
that position
and you know not steal from them but try
to take pieces and parts of their game
and
uh their lifestyle and their work ethic
and add in the mind and try to create my
own
monster i guess you could say i have
faith in him because
he's already hit the payday but he's
still humble
still respectful still wanting to learn
and grow so feel something he wants
yeah when he gets humble we don't want
anything anymore
we still young you know you're so proud
your family name is gonna be put through
sports history
you know you should be proud for that
the legacy of it yeah the barclays
so you say you know my uncle yeah he's
crazy though
you owe his uncle money don't you mike
no that's what i heard
about you i just heard you make what the
[ __ ] up man give me some money [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] up out here so his uncle was
a bad man
not a bad man a badass fighter that's
what i mean
yeah three-time champ that's amazing
yeah
i boxed a little when i was younger but
like i never i was like was in love with
football
but that's something i like i love like
the training like boxing training is
like
extremely hard and that's stuff that i
was doing last year and obviously was my
knee continued hill
i'm gonna get back into it what's wrong
with maniscus yeah i did i took my acl
my mc on my meniscus
oh you got it oh yeah normally there's
only one of them
yeah yeah but imagine a guy like this
who's training that
now all you're putting all that energy
and effort into that
so you're that much stronger now yeah
but i'm not i'm not to be honest
that's something that like i'm trying to
like because ap obviously if ap had like
probably the best comeback story
especially at a running back after
tearing his knee up coming back rushed
for 2000 yards
and i'll talk to his trainer and the
biggest thing that i took from it
uh he was saying that we didn't just
rehab the knee
we rehab the whole body we focus on from
from toes all the way up to the brain to
the mind how you're going to challenge
yourself
and i feel like everything happened for
a reason i'm a big believer in that
and adversity is going to come in
everyone's life and you know you got to
welcome it and you got to accept the
challenges and
that's something that i'm facing right
now and i'm going to try to use that so
like
like i keep saying catapult me to be a
better player than i was not just as
not just on the field but leadership um
just understanding the game the mental
part of it
all that kind in one do you feel even
stronger because of this rehab
just holistically yeah i mean challenge
you man
it it challenges you um it sucks like i
said very few people come
come back from [ __ ] i know i know he got
all three of them they normally don't
come back from one of them yeah you know
right
and that's that's that's a challenge you
hear people
talk about that and you know people
there's people that's going to be out
there that's going to count me out but
you can't really listen to that like you
say kind of going back to yourself it's
the expectations you set for yourself
the conversations that you have yourself
and i know what i'm capable of doing i
know what i'm going to be able to do
but it goes and starts back with just
taking it one day at a time
and try to focus on getting one percent
better um and i'm a big believer the
rest will take care of itself
but you can also take that the people
that doubt you or the haters however
you want to classify them and use it as
motivation
yeah i agree with that but that's that's
something that
i mean since we're just being open
honest here that's something i'm not
doing no more
um i don't need other people's
uh energy to feed me i love it it starts
with myself and i think like
going in my bed going into the week that
hurt my knee uh there was a lot of talk
about me there's some legends that said
some negative things about me media was
talking negative about me and in the
game i was
it was short game but i was so pressed
you know i wanted to go out there and
shut everyone up
i wasn't doing it for the love of the
game i was doing it to shut everyone up
and that was kind of like the first time
where i think i honestly could say and
look back at myself and say
where i did that i wasn't playing just
as a little kid out there and loving the
game and just trying to be great
i was going out there to make a
statement and shut everyone up and
i guess uh that happened interesting
you got outside yourself yep that's
heavy
i like that i think it happens to us all
right
that's that's called being human yeah
you had some some injuries back in the
day
oh man all the time but i think yeah i
fought my injuries i didn't
care i just wanted to get my hands on
the guy
right you know this is almost like a
street fight if you're in the street
fight a guy ain't gonna say
i'm not gonna fight you you gotta cut
you got stitches on your eye
it's the same thing
what do you think like was the biggest
challenge for you throughout your career
like
like where was that moment where you
think that obviously that confidence is
inside of you
but where you kind of redirected from
that and kind of lost yourself
in that aspect in many
many occasions many occasions
that had happened and then i had to
learn from that
and prevent it happening again because
like you you mentioned adversity and
and the only thing adversity do is make
the week weaker and the strong stronger
and i decided to be on the stronger side
of adversity
i'm never gonna not accomplish what i
want to accomplish
you know why because i'm willing to die
to accomplish what i want to accomplish
my life means nothing
maybe it's my ego for fame and what it
is but that's the only thing that
matters to me my preeminence
in the future besides kids and family
exactly
for me personally personally yeah and
it's interesting you get it because
pro football players have an even more
of a finite amount of time
yeah mike especially my position yeah
sorry go ahead i'm saying especially the
position i play the running back
position
yeah but you gotta like like like i said
that adversary like when i when i hurt
my knee
like i ain't gonna lie like that's
probably the
the weakest moment of my life um
especially those first two days
like i just couldn't control myself
crying
that's why me why me why me and then
yeah i just like that
third day just hit and i'm just like so
what now what it's just saying that my
coach
coach burns always telling me so what
now what and um
now what it happened so like you said
the adversity make the week weaker and
makes a strong stronger
you got to pick and choose what side you
want to be on and
i just i know no matter what uh if
i came back and say the things didn't go
the way it i don't
envision it going which i can't see that
because that's the way i envision it
but i know i'm gonna do everything
necessary
to put myself in the right position um
the smart way in the right way
to to come back better and if it's not
in the car to me to do it at least i
know i can look myself in the mirror
and know i put the work ethic and i did
the little things i
you know all the all the things that
matter to try to make myself
become one of the best to do it and if
it don't happen um
i know i put the work in at least it's
going to happen
yeah i would say it will happen you get
the right perspective
yeah on the right path for sure man you
know i always you know you have to
believe that um
you have you you were here and descended
from god to do this
yeah it's just because it's just true
they take advantage of it and you're a
good guy respectful young man
a lot of good things going to happen to
you i appreciate that
i was actually watching i think you were
playing the bears when you got injured
correct
that's right i was watching that game
being from chicago
yeah we get to go back there next year
though so that's definitely a little
motivation
absolutely is there anybody out there in
the field that you're scared of when
they come in at you
no no there you go i hear that
i mean it may sound cocky or whatever
but like i have that mindset when i'm on
the field that i'm the best on the field
um that no one can touch me um and
that's the things that i feel like has
made me
uh even if i'm having a bit like there's
days like this you're gonna have your
bad games there's gonna be days that
you you don't uh the game don't go your
way um
especially with football football such a
team sport that's why it's my favorite
sport i mean i love sports all around
but
i think it's the biggest team sport all
time no matter how much talent that you
have especially
the position i play you can be blessed
with all the talent you want in the
world
but it's on a run play it takes five
offensive linemen a tight end and wide
receivers to all be on the same page
and you'll be on the same page for that
run play to work in between if you do
that part of the game
good a crappy quarterback if it's
running back to go through
exactly yeah exactly so um that's why my
mind says
i guess like a lot of people say i'm a
i'm a home run hitter
um it's either all or nothing for me um
which
is something i i i can agree and you
know you can
you got to learn and then learn when to
take the little things and take the runs
but
um i'm i'm a believer that no matter
where we are
whether we're on the one yard line or
the opposite warrior line
when the ball is my hand that i'm a
threat to take it to the house and score
a touchdown so i know you're 22 years
old so what are you planning on what
idea you plan on doing after this is
over uh stuff like this
um you know uh michael stran uh you know
michael strahan yeah
um obviously a giants legend hell of a
player
i think even if you ask him you know
he's probably more successful
um outside of football and uh i love
sports i love conversations i love
talking to people like this conversation
i don't like i'm not trying to be a fan
fan person right here but this
conversation mean a lot to me like
people who could challenge your mind and
just open up and have dialogue about
things and
i love doing that so you especially when
it comes to football i can't play
football forever but i can talk about it
for a very long time so
i would love to be uh on tv and talking
about sports
like an analyst or a broadcaster um
that's the career side of it but
gail sears was a little bit like barry
yeah but before
before him gail sayers he just passed
away this year too actually yeah
well yeah god rest his soul
it's funny because strahan did a
i was on a show called entourage and
that's how i met mike and that's how i
met strahan
and i remember meeting mike and just
thinking
he's so charismatic and i you know not
to be the guy that's playing monday
morning quarterback
saying that i called it but i talked to
him and i said you've got
a real future like like mike in front of
the camera because these guys are so
charismatic yeah
and it just you know their path is
they're going to do their thing but also
having someone who's already in that
arena saying
i i see you and i recognize you and
you're going to be great it just helps
it helps the whole journey it makes you
feel i'm in the right place
absolutely absolutely and you're really
humble and you're so successful and it's
a great combination
so where you live new york nah so i was
i was born in new york i was born to
bronx
um but my parents felt it would be
better for me and my family
if we moved out so like when i was like
five six years old
um my parents moved me and my siblings
to pennsylvania
um right yeah and that's when i kind of
i guess pa's
home so i'm from new york i got the new
york times
somebody from new york to move somewhere
yeah so
that's what i said is uh sacrifice that
my parents made you know they gave up a
lot
left a lot of their family um in new
york and made a sacrifice for
their kids and um you know so far it's
great i ran hit you up for money
uh no no no no no no i actually um i did
i did a book bag giveaway the last time
i seen them uh
in the summer i think was it last year
or this year this summer
um and that's the last time i saw him um
but you know he's he's been awesome to
me um
lucky to have him my corner i feel like
obviously you know he has successful
boston career but the things i learned
the most
is um you know his
his downfalls in life and that's
something that um
growing up i was always you know kind of
conscious yeah
like conscious of like people mistakes
like you can learn a lot from
the positivity and things that people do
and you can learn what not to do so um
that's something that i would say
being growing up and knowing of my uncle
and and knowing the mistakes that my
father's made and
so on and so on people my family um i'll
be a fool uh to make the same damn
mistake so
i try to learn from them and teach shows
on to my kids and so on and so on
it's great that you have that because as
they say there's no playbook
for fame you know walking through it i
mean i
i can't even imagine what it was like
for you mike back in the day because
there was nothing
i'm a street guy from brooklyn right and
i
it was cool but once it got like when i
get the [ __ ] away from me [ __ ]
you could have got
too much yeah i couldn't they don't know
if my mother died they don't know
my sister they don't know if i broke up
with my girlfriend and it's running in
my face and
that's crazy but that's what's great for
you is you could talk to your uncle yeah
yeah not just i mean like i have a great
a great family you know i'm blessed to
have
uh two parents are alive and still
together a lot of people's not blessed
with that and
you know i've been very fortunate so you
know i'm blessed in that area
um to to learn from the positive things
that my parents and my families have
done
and learn from negative things and try
my best you know i'm human everyone's
gonna make mistakes
um but try my best not to make those
same mistakes and um
like i said um i have a daughter and
hopefully future kids
two years old awesome yeah two years old
um
terrible twos is a real thing yeah to
say the least
yeah uh like i said so i'm very blessed
for every boss do you meditate no that's
something that uh
my dad my dad does um and you know he's
talked to me about it
but like i don't know like what do you
what do you count as meditate like i
don't sit in my room
with my legs crossed and like meditating
like sometimes like
i think if you're having a conversation
with yourself and uh just bringing those
positive thoughts to yourself
um it's the same thing right it's just
subconsciously visualizing
yeah you know i mean you focus on this
that issue
with every iota and your your molecules
and everything
yeah you meditate i'm assuming
i pretty much die
and i'm meditating and stuff i'm like i
said i'm i'm i'm
like a borderline shaman i use plant and
animal medicine
i won't say i've been enlightened but i
said um i've had
i had um divine divine feelings yeah
well i've i've never like experienced or
took it to that level but i mean
that's something that uh i know some
players who do it too
me i like i'm always trying to find any
way uh
to gain advantage on your opponents and
um to try to
like i said to try to bring the best out
of you and uh i talked to my dad about
that and
that's something that i wouldn't say i'm
not willing to try you know
it's interesting your reference for
meditation you said you know
sitting cross-legged and crystals and
stuff like that because it's
things that we don't really know about
are intimidating
you know and it's just you ask what
meditation is
it's just you know it doesn't have to be
intimidating it's just taking 15 minutes
every morning
and quieting your thoughts yeah and
focusing on your breath
and you could do all those things
because you were such i mean
the discipline you've had to had to get
to the point that you're at just
to sit and be present with yourself and
then you're just
working on a higher vibration i'm not
you know i'm not trying to peddle
uh meditation on anyone i'm just saying
it works
you know if i didn't do it i'd probably
be in trouble well i was told this i was
told silence was
god's language so that's why we meditate
yeah it's beautiful that's deep and it's
it's
it's a little intimidating but once you
do it and you don't beat yourself up
because you're going to have those
thoughts
and you just let them pass and you're
silent and then
you just go to another level and by the
way there has to be something to it it's
been around for thousands of years
and we're still talking about it yeah
there must be something to it
believed it yeah the ones that are
aware of it the meditating thing is
something i gotta
the meditation sometimes make you think
what do you think you're really doing
here do you think you navigated your
life by working hard you navigated your
life to become this guy
do you think that or do you think it's
something more powerful that's bigger
than you that
directed you in this position but see i
like
i don't meditate but i i kind of already
view that
like i'm i'm a big believer in a higher
being and um
that's why like i feel like god has put
me in a position
with it blessed me with a talent um that
he bless you with a bloodline
what do you mean by that having having
um very athletic people in your family
before you
um i would say maybe
but like i think the move from
new york to pennsylvania um kind of
like i'm always i guess you say besides
my uncle uh i would say we have a lot of
athletes a lot of people who box but
like
football is not like really that uh well
known in new york
which i would love to try to definitely
expand on it and make it well known
but i feel like yes i i can confidently
say i feel like
i was blessed with a talent um
that put me in a position that had may
have brought
some spotlight and attention to me and i
feel like it's
what you do with that um what do you
feel you should do with that
it's the impact i think that's what
would you do with that it's
impact um i know we're not in a perfect
world but that's what i'm trying to do
like i said i know i make mistakes but
especially like i think my fan base and
a lot of people that follow me are kids
and a lot of kids look up to me um and
i've i've taken notes of that so
that's why you know i try to do things
in the right way but i also say like i
was i'll say all the time i'm human so
the mistakes i
i make in life um i'll be open and
honest about that too because kids can
learn from that too
so you may not have a impact on
100 000 of people it may be only 15 and
20
but if i can honestly confidently say
that i've made an impact
by just the way how i approach the game
how i approach life or how i treat
others
and i could say i changed a couple of
people's life then
i could say when it's all said and done
i i did something positive
towards this world you what i mean i
understand
yeah because think about it the way
mike's impacting you right now right
with him now this is a big deal to me i
ain't gonna lie i'm not trying because
this camera's on so i'm trying to like
each other but this is
being honest um think of you have that
impact on
on these kids that are following you do
you know what i'm saying just what
you're feeling right now and that's
heavy that's beautiful
you know that's what it's all about yeah
no don't take that for granted
you know your leader not income lead you
would be the leader
no no
what's that spider-man quote like at the
end the first spider-man
oh great well great power comes great
responsibility exactly
something like that exactly so like like
i said like you you know
uh that just all eyes on you especially
being in new york um
you know i love new york but uh being a
a well-known athlete in new york you
know that they're just waiting
uh for you for you to make that mistake
and like i said there's gonna be
something
i'm human there's gonna be something i
don't think i've really made a crazy
mistake yet but there's going to be
something in it
and when i do make that mistake be open
honest um about it
um and when i'm asked about it
like those like i said those lessons and
the mistakes that you make in life can
also have
just as much maybe even more of an
impact on the positive things that you
do
absolutely in your life it could be a
gift because of your rehab
do you feel like you're training in a
weird way more than ever and there are
almost no down time um preparing no it's
more like
it's like i started over like i had to
like
i had to train myself how to walk again
i'm still
i'm still doing that like it's like
obviously like just
getting the extension in the leg like
your your full extension while you're
walking and
um just doing that and then like i'm
known for like having big legs i guess
you could say
and then like you like you lose a lot of
muscle so now i'm getting my muscle back
um and then you focus on stuff that you
probably didn't focus on before
i'm a very powerful guy especially like
when it comes to like the weight room
um that's something i've been known for
[ __ ] baby
uh max bench i think it's 455 or 465.
i've been down uh
yep strong [ __ ] too yeah uh
but like in weight room i've always been
been strong but now i'm focusing on
little things
so tell me more about you man you have
friends what are you doing in
play time i'm i am a
passionate guy uh i love i'm a loving
guy
i love family i love my family my
friends i'm about like if i'm if i'm
about your own about you like i'm rather
die
um and i have like people like people
around me that
are people that not that only could
trust but also challenge me i
don't got like yes man around me and i
know some like some people might have
that but like me personally like
i got people that if i'm in a wrong or
if i'm doing something wrong
whether it's from my family to my close
friends um to
teammates uh who look in my eye and say
say give your [ __ ]
give it to you straight do you do you
have people that weren't in your crew
before you had money no i wouldn't
really say so i mean because all like
it kind of all came in like whether
through high school or whether it's in
college
um i would say though some i've added
some like your teammates
um whether it's like a sterling shepherd
or
um uh dale jones and those guys or every
ingram those guys like i guess you could
say
we're i wasn't friends with them until
i've got money because i was in the nfl
um
but not really i i i keep my
keep my circles small um
and just like i said keep people around
me that not only are
like great people but they also
challenge you too if you're you're wrong
they're gonna let you know you're wrong
if you're i love it
you're right i love it because mike is
mike has been through it
he's seen it mm-hmm gotta keep one yes
man with you god damn nah that's not
that's not it for me i had
one guy say man yeah man do this man i
mean like i feel like i gotta do this
i have like i have people like i guess
you could say my management company that
that work within my management company
but
i'm like will they do stuff for me like
yes but it's never like in a form of
like a disrespect like of me like
trying to abuse that power you know it's
all like mutual respect like i said like
there's some of my close friends i knew
since i was in high school and growing
up
so you don't want those people around
you man you know what i mean
sometimes when you have people working
for you they take the position a little
too serious
and we can't have fun you know we think
every time we take ourselves serious
we can't have fun but when we laugh at
ourselves we always have fun
there you go you know that's i mean it's
easier
said than done to not take things
personally but
it's heavy once you embrace it oh yes
laugh is a joke baby it's a joke
it's one of the things that i've one of
the many things i've learned from mike
is how you know there have been people
in his past that have taken advantage of
him
and he doesn't hold a grudge lives in
forgiveness
i don't know about that i mean i'm not
oh yeah listen yeah i'm not like
you're not ready brother i'm not like
can you you do me wrong
no you cross the line like i cut ties
like
the devil will win the devil win so
you're saying the devil wins because
someone did me wrong
and i cut ties with that person act like
i never met that person yeah
so i got to be the bigger person because
he changed you
oh okay so he's your math
because he controls your emotions he's
not your enemy he's your master
because he's not who you used to be now
he stole that away from you
well you allowed him to he can't do it
if you don't know
that's hard though man that's once you
think you're great now
that's how great you're gonna be when
you learn compassion and empathy
oh yeah well listen when i was you i
wanted to be a savage i was a savage and
no doubt about it i want everybody to be
afraid of me
now i want everybody to love me you know
the trip
mm-hmm you may you know you're not gonna
be 22 for long
life go back flick of your eye you know
you might be a minister
you never know you know my
life changes us we're born and then
something happens
and then we meet god
life is just a flicker okay
and i think because of his energy
because he has so much compassion and
forgiveness
people are drawn to him and he still
can't figure it out but i think those
are some of the variables
because a guy that could be that tough
and that ruthless and we've watched he's
been in our living rooms
we've seen him do these things and yet
he doesn't hold grudges
i know that i mean that's like i got
hats off like i mean like i said he
keeps saying i'm i'm 23 20 23 years old
yeah you guys see him
and i i got ways to go me personally
right now
like now i like i'm i'm a person that
always try to take advice and listen and
learn like i never looked at
that aspect that you doing that the
devil wins
so that's a that's a whole different
different outlook of what i've had on it
before
but me personally before i think i'll
probably think about it differently
i'm just like i don't know i feel like
i'm a guy that a loving guy and like
once i give you that trust and like once
i allow you in my life like that
and like for you to turn your back and
do something shitey to me
like i can i can confidently say right
now
i'm not at that point as a man what
happened to all the prophets happened to
all the gods
they're not bigger than them
but they're bigger than nothing they can
forgive and show passion
and we're supposedly following them
they're our prophets
we should have their compassion but i i
mean like it's some things in this world
that like some people can do to you and
that like
you just like and you can still forgive
them there's nothing in the world
someone can do to you that you can't
forgive them you don't gotta [ __ ] with
them you don't gotta hang out with them
that would be cool too but you don't
gotta do that [ __ ] but to clear your
soul you have to forgive them because
you having all that
intense energy towards towards them that
is
you're doing all the energy you're
creating it so if you cut that down
you have a better long living status of
life
than you would as a focus and all that
energy on this negative guy until you
believe
that you're wrong which he did and if
you have compassion
i can't forgive the person but still cut
them off you know what i mean
yeah like in my heart so you're saying
like within your heart forgive them but
just cut them off
yeah yeah so you're saying like within
your heart like you don't have to like
feed into that negative no you don't
have to think oh i want to kill that
[ __ ]
if nobody's around i would kick knife
leave them alone that's too much stress
on you
because if you hold on to that that's
like you taking poison
and hoping they die yeah and plus he
wins because you got to take the energy
since you're not [ __ ] with him little
[ __ ] with who
you're closest to your woman your boys
your kids
don't let these guys give you that take
that much power away from you
don't let them use you or own you
otherwise you're just acting out of
revenge all the time
absolutely and when you're looking for
revenge you always make a fool out of
yourself
you're not thinking what brains yeah
well i haven't really so far in my life
i can confidence i can say
they haven't been in that situation but
hopefully it doesn't happen but like i
said like life is life
and when that does happen i mean that's
that's the way i think that's
the more man thing to do the more like
not man things not the right thing to
say especially in today's
today's world but like the the the right
way to do it though
don't keep that negativity in your heart
it's like it's like being the older man
the underman
is because there's this friend german
guy named frederick nietzsche
and he talked about being the older man
over man takes everybody's garbage
he eats everybody craps and he doesn't
do
nothing and that makes him better than
everybody to do crap at him
because he took it and he didn't do
nothing
and that's why the old man became so
synonymous with
god right
nietzsche you you really didn't think we
would be talking about nietzsche here
did you
no we thought you thought we would be
talking about yards per carry
no i i knew i knew it was i was not
concerned but i kept asking i was like
what is i have no idea what we're going
to go and talk about
yeah at first i'm like oh okay it's the
hot box the hot boxing
so obviously you mean it's it's honored
to be talking to you guys
but i had no idea where we were going to
the direction we were going to but
i mean so far in this conversation i
feel like
learn a lot by myself and the people who
are watching got to see a different
side of me i guess so too do you think
you ever lived before
you think you ever lived before another
century or anything
oh think it's possible
do i think i've ever lived before
no you think you will after you die do i
believe in life after death
i do i do
i i mean that's i think that's where
faith comes in having faith in heart
being
now religiously i'm not too really big
into religion
yet that's something i feel like i can
still um
get into but i think it starts with
having faith in god right now
um but do i believe in life after death
yes but i'm not like two
like i'm not two when you're angel
you're demon
like i mean i'm i have my father i
should have i wish my father was here
right now like this would be a whole
like youtube like these my father and
him in the room together in a
conversation
would be literally like must watch tv
but um
you can't be an angel so like so my like
i think like
yours like you your energy like your
soul lives on afters
but like if they're like the am i like
okay you go to that you go to the gates
of heaven or you go to hell
i'm not too sure about that right now
but i do believe that there's a life and
death and i do believe that
the way you live your life on this earth
does have a play a part until how you
spend their afterlife
but like to say like like all that i
don't i'm not
too sure into that right into that right
now
do you know who you were in another life
mike i have no idea no idea
so like is i like deja vu and would that
be like something like
there's some stuff like you're like
like you feel some stuff you're like why
why do i feel it before
so i i guess but i don't i've never
thought about it like that like
like me and my boys and people have like
these conversations all the time and
just dialogues about anything but i i
would say like do i believe i was
someone
before this that's a hard that's that's
like
i can't say yes but like i said i know i
just said no but i can't say yes and i
can't say
no because i i truly don't know
but i don't i don't think so
i don't i don't think so but i do
believe in life after that
i mean think about it when you're around
certain people you feel more comfortable
than others you we all
have gifts that we are we take to faster
than others
that's unexplainable yeah we only use 10
percent of our brain
so they say it's hard to yeah so like
you could like make the argument that
like like this
like i talked to my dad about the other
day like this is just a
like host exactly you believe like your
soul like
your energy like carries on and carries
on and carries on
so that's like i guess you could say the
same thing if like agreeing what i said
that i believe in life after death
because that would be a different type
of life after death
like it may not be like to heaven or to
hell but like if your soul continues to
carry on carry on
like you're still living after this this
body absolutely people that have near
death experience they talk
about their spirit and the spirit
continues on
my little french bulldog died in my arms
recently and i hope his spirit carries
on
i always think they always think um
people that died turn to animals
is that uh i think my dog is one of my
friends absolutely
right without a doubt i believe that
yeah
the way they look at you they're saying
mike the [ __ ] [ __ ] is me
you felt that you got kids i do have a
kid i have a daughter jada claire
yeah yeah cool how old is she too two
years old
turns three in april she was
yeah no february i got drafted
april 26 and she was born
april 24th wow and so like two days
before i got drafted
so i got to like experience two of my
dreams like i got to become a father
and then two days later i got to go into
the nfl and
start that start that path off too
that's heavy
your family said go ahead baby go ahead
baby girl yeah
it was fun it was fun i had my
like that that was probably um that week
for me getting drafted it was amazing
because like i said
two days prior i got to see the birth of
my daughter and then i was able to
actually still travel to dallas texas
and
have my family have my loved ones there
and um you know all the hard work that i
put in
just to get to that moment um and have
the people with me
oh man can i get water please
what contact you getting [ __ ]
the money they giving you these white
people
oh um i'm not even focused on that right
now to be honest like
it's it's so obviously i want to play
for the giants as long as i can
um hopefully be a giant for the rest of
my life uh but right now
i feel like the best thing i do for not
only myself but for my team which is
focus on
uh getting this knee right and preparing
myself to get ready for the season
whenever i'm able to come back to play
[ __ ] they offer you a lot of money man
barkley
they offer you that grizzly
you don't need to do this [ __ ] once now
you [ __ ] around get your back [ __ ] up
you can't get to grizzly
yeah but you can't you you've had your
back [ __ ] up you played right through
you worked through it it's not it's it's
not a career ending
situation get together yeah
i feel like that i feel like i'm a big
believer everything's going to take care
of itself
so if i have the right work i think the
right mindset and try to do the little
things right
everything's going to take care of
itself there you go and that's the best
way i can answer that i want a difficult
contract guys before you get in my car
you gotta buy my mother a house you
gotta get dead
you gotta buy me some dope then you give
me my contract
mm-hmm you're a good guy huh
yeah how about my mom yeah that was a
before actually
before i got drafted i was able to buy
my mom my house
um i always say my mom like i don't know
why i would say that my mom and my dad
house
um but like i said my parents done so
much for me
that uh and i know the sacrifices and
obviously we didn't grow up
with a lot um but we always made what
made right what we had and
um you know god put me position to have
a little money in my life so
uh to be able to buy my mama house and
probably one of my biggest
accomplishments
if not a nice kid he's an angel he's a
sweet kid
you can feel it right mike can see these
things too because if he didn't believe
it he would tell you
yeah believe me i listen to current
karen company i'm very
he's sensitive mike is very sensitive i
appreciate that
he's a mama's boy mama
i am too i can feel you man the mama's
boys
yeah as we wind down
anything that you wanted to ask the
champion you may want to ask
jeremy yeah i don't know if he has a
reference for me he definitely has a
reference for you mike
you seen it that's he's a little young
i've actually never watched entre there
you go to be honest mike i've got
moisturizer on that's older than he is
okay a 23 year old [ __ ] man
he's young i would say all right for
both of you guys
like when did like in your careers like
when did like it click for you guys
like not like like not like when like
you may have
became the heavyweight champ at 20 or
you may have
reached a part of your career at a
certain age but when did it click and
you're like all right
i'm the greatest of all time 15 15
15. what happened to 15 that let you
know that i won the nationals twice
i knocked everybody out and then i
fought some
um they called club match where you
fight anybody any age
i knocked everybody out in that
tournament
and so i thought i beat the world junior
champion
knocked him out so i thought i was the
man you were about 190 pounds at 15.
yeah
okay and and you were even earlier lying
about your age to fight older
guys yeah interesting that's heavy
i wish my story was that interesting um
listen here's the reality of my
my story is i'm a little bit different
on paper i won
the fresh face of the year at 37 years
old
and when i accepted my award i said
there's nothing fresh about my face
but thank you so on paper i was a late
bloomer
mike was an early bloomer youngest
heavyweight champ but for me i just had
to stick it out because i knew it was
going to happen
it was just a question of when and we
started seeing in movies and stuff we
with some and bad
things very very bad thing that was
awesome
that was twisted beautiful very twisted
it was an exploration of bad karma and
it was
very very ma'am guess how many times
guys went out together went to vegas and
some really weird
stuff happened you know they may they
may have got a stripper that want to do
them all sudden she's doing too many
pills and she just passed out boom he
thinks she's dead
it was a very dark twisted movie
yeah yeah realistic though i mean i
i come from an acting family and a
theater family so
you know mike was asking you know what
things are proud of like with me being
from chicago
we had a program called off the street
club and we took kids from the south
side of chicago
everyone's on scholarship we bring them
in and we teach them
improv scene study and so we're giving
people
all on scholarship a chance to see what
it's like to be an actor yeah
you know when they never they thought
well okay i love denzel but i could
never do that myself
and so it's a chance to for people to
actually touch it and have a reference
for it
you know like what you guys were talking
about earlier this you're having a
moment with mike and then you're going
to have
that with kids and i was lucky enough to
to touch people
in the theater growing up like that
since i'm on the top of the kit like so
another question youtube what would be
the best advice you'll give to a young
kid or
you know a teenager that's coming up in
their profession wherever their
profession may be whether you want to be
a boxer a football player
actor um a scientist like what would be
the best advice
that you can give that kid that's a
great question
i think to realize that you're enough
sometimes that people don't realize that
they're enough
when we would go up on stage and we'd be
asked to improvise
you know if you're nervous and you doubt
yourself or you're listening and you're
a slave to your
fears and doubts and thoughts you're
going to be a lesser version of yourself
you know so never make yourself small
you own the space that you occupy and
you're enough
and the two-year-old and stuff and your
mother
your whole mission should be to make
them happy and make them have what they
never had
before in their life that would be your
mission
you have everything else you got the
skills you got the platform
now you got to be an entrepreneur take
care of your family and teach them how
to take care of their family
you know you could break the cycle of
whatever it was that
wasn't good to your family drugs or
whatever it was
and that's what this all really about
you know
put our ego aside i'm the best in the
world i'm the best in the world in order
to do this for my family my friends the
people that i love
that's all what this [ __ ] is about no
ego i'm the best you know we gotta
deal with that too we gotta you know
give gift ourselves
but you know it's all about taking care
of people all this stuff we got
helping people they can't help
themselves exactly
wow thank you saquon barkley for joining
us
thank you hey man it's beautiful some
deep
deep deep stuff here it was fun though
thank you learn a lot what are you gonna
do right now when you leave what are you
gonna
do work out and then i got rehab
yeah all about working out man
walter payton just worked out 26 hours a
day he is
all day walk the pain worked out all day
he used to run this hill by my house no
the dirtier right
i live down the street from there this
is what i do right here boom that dirty
ugly hill
yep joe's one of my sprinted up that bad
boy
he was old school he would just take
weights in his hands and get on that
trampoline stuff that we
had kind of never seen before you know
he was about
listed at 510 he really was about five
five nine
but playing like that running through
people
that to you my man good luck i
appreciate it
i'm a chicago bears fan but now i have
to give it up to the jedi
where they had laurence taylor also when
you get your new contract
i want to borrow some money we'll talk
we'll talk
we'll talk interesting the interest
thank you guys thank you guys
you